it's very clear why bill taylor deserves
the john honor medal of commendation
and i have the distinct honor tonight of
presenting it to my very good friend and
colleague
bill taylor
[Music]
thank
you
oh my goodness
um
thank you
uh thank you all so much uh thanks to
the
scientific and uh
technology i'm sorry thanks to the
scitec awards committee
thanks to the board of governors
well i thought i would save time tonight
just by giving the uncut version of john
john the erlang speech from last year
now that's only partly a that's
that's only partly a joke because i
endorse pretty much everything he had to
say
and judging from the applause at the
time so did most of us in this room
i am so proud to be a member of this
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences
john reminded us of the academy's
mission
a mission just as relevant today as when
it was created
the pursuit of excellence in all aspects
of motion pictures
we give awards we put on a wonderful
award show we're building a world-class
museum
and it's all in service to that ideal
excellence in all aspects of motion
pictures
i hope we never lose track of the
distinction between our mission
and the means of realizing it
now we've had some pretty uh formidable
achievements of our own of course the
aces standard which hawk mentioned
earlier this year that bears our name
it's the academy
color encoding standard
recognized around the world
our the council's work
in
solid state lighting
in color science
and in many other branches of motion
picture technology
has really set the standard of the world
and it's our volunteer members who set
these standards and i'd like to talk
about one of them
man very dear to my heart my friend and
mentor petra vlahos
he held no economic degrees beyond a ba
the first time i met him i said oh dr
vlahos it's such a pleasure to meet you
that
someone of his
distinction would have at least
a doctorate but no
but he
had his head screwed on straight
as another ward award winner david
grafton once said
and it's hard to emphasize
the import of his inventions
he solved huge problems
that had resisted years of well-funded
research and development and concerted
effort by his predecessors and by his
peers
he was the chief scientist of the
research council
the direct president for the technology
council today
i knew him in those days from reading
about his inventions in the
uh simply journal
i met him at a usc class he taught on
the color difference system
one of his really important inventions
uh pete as he preferred to be called
became a friend
he was a life coach
for lack of a better term
and one day
about 1972
he sponsored me for academy membership
he drafted me onto the scitec awards
committee
so he has a lot to do with my standing
here right now
some might say he has a lot to answer
for
his most important achievement
went well well beyond solving an urgent
problem of the day
his invention made a whole genre of
films possible
the genre of films that seems to make
more money than any other
because he created not just one or two
systems
but he created
the whole of composite photography as we
know it in the present time
blue screen
green screen
an important contribution to the sodium
vapor system which he actually
reinvented without realizing it
and in both photographic
analog video and digital software
embodiments
this is one guy
so
whenever you see mary poppins dancing
with penguins
when you see pie in a boat in the middle
of the ocean
when you see any of tens of thousands of
composites
made
with his patents at their root
you are seeing pete blahos genius at
work
he had a long tenure on the scitec
awards committee this committee
and he created the guidelines now known
in his honor
as the blah host criteria
that we use to judge awards like you've
seen presented this evening
in addition to two oscars he was awarded
this medal
before it even bore john bonner's name
more than anything
in words and by example
he also taught me
a lot about life
he taught me the value of reason
the relationship between reason and
emotion
and how the clarity that results from
that relationship is the foundation of
understanding and achievement
tonight i'm sorry to tell you that pete
plajo's journey has reached its end
he leaves no unfinished business
he lived a life full of achievement and
honor
and the love of his family
an example for any of us
i always try to find an opportunity to
thank my mentors
along with pete al whitlock and lynn
dunn
to whom i owe a lifetime's debt of
gratitude
but as my wife kay reminded me a few
weeks ago
none of us who volunteer our time to the
academy could do so without the support
of our families our colleagues and our
businesses
our unseen partners
our bulwark our foundation
so i add profound thanks to my business
partner my friend the brilliant artist
sid dutton
for making what i've done with the
academy possible
you know it's pretty intimidating
an award given in the past to uh
petro uh
john irland ray finney talk nagashima
lynn dunn rod ryan
dick stumpf
so many more
and of course john bonder himself
i don't think any person has ever given
more of his life to this academy than
john bonner
to be even thought of in this company is
an incredible honor
and
frankly a bit of a stretch
all the same
i'm
profoundly honored to accept the john a
bonner medal as a source of inspiration
and as an ideal
and ideal i promise you to which i will
continue to aspire thank you so much
you